find the value of five to the third  power let me rewrite that we have five  to the third power now it's important to  remember this does not mean five times  three  this means five times itself three times  so this is equal to  five  times five  times five  five times three just as a bit of a  refresher so you realize the difference  five times  which let me write it over here  5 times 3  5 times 3  is equal to 5  plus 5  plus 5. so when you multiply by 3 you're  adding the number two itself three times  when you take it to the third power  you're multiplying the number by itself  three times so five times three you've  seen that before that's fifteen but five  to the third power five times itself  three times is equal to  well five times five is 25 and then 25  times five is 125  so this is equal to 120  and we're done